- That paved way for, "Inception".
- I love that you just knocked
over N'Sync's members here.
Justin Timberlake and Joey Fatone.
Can we take note even
though he just punched
them off to the side like that.
- I didn't, I didn't mean to.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry my friends.
- Boy bands, there's
a whole bunch of them.
But admittedly, two titans
towered over the rest:
O-Town and BBMak.
Just kidding.
Backstreet Boyz versus N'Sync.
It's debatable.
(triumphant music)
- I am pro N'Sync
- And I am pro Backstreet Boyz.
- I'm team N'Sync.
- Backstreet's back?
Backstreet never left mother (beep)
- I'm for N'Sync.
- And I'm for the Backstreet Boyz.
- And I am N'Sync for life.
- And I am BSB for life.
- N'Sync is the greatest
boy band of all time.
N'Sync has one of the
greatest entertainers
of our world in their band.
Also known as, Justin Randall Timberlake.
- And his back up band.
- N'Sync gave us Justin and Britney.
That is so huge.
They wore matching denim outfits
and that'll forever be
in our brains and hearts.
- I thought that I was
personally going to marry JC
and he was my straight girl crush.
And then I'm gay.
- Justin Timberlake, JC Chasez,
we got Lance Bass, we got
Chris Kirkpatrick, Joey Fatone.
- Do you even know Brian's last name?!
- You mean, Littrell?
- You know who's the only person
that you can compare Justin Timberlake to?
Michael Jackson.
You know who I can compare Nick Carter to?
The guy who helped me
out with my groceries
at Vons yesterday.
- We got, "Bye Bye Bye",
we got a little, "feel the pain"
we got this shit, we got
"No Strings Attached",
shit going on.
- That video changed my life.
- How?
- It made me want to be a puppet.
- We all know that N'Sync is one member.
It's Justin Timberlake.
Everyone else is glorified backup dancers.
- Wow! Okay.
- Doo wop, shoo wop.
- First off,
(laughs)
- They had the best music
videos of that time period.
They were on TRL number
1, like every (bleep) day.
- Yeah but who did it first?
Backstreet Boys.
- "Bye Bye Bye" might
be a top ten song, ever.
- Where are they now?
They went, "Bye Bye".
(screams)
- N'Sync stopped being a band
because Justin Timberlake left.
But Backstreet Boys are a band.
- 1999, TRL, "I Want It
That Way" music video,
dances all in white,
- From the second that you saw the boys
walking down the runway, in that airport,
you knew that you had
an iconic music video.
- No, I became gay in that moment.
- the crowd's singing, Kevin's solo.
Come on.
I mean like,
- Kevin, who?
- This dude Kevin, left.
He straight up bounced for five years.
- Without the Backstreet
Boys, first and foremost,
there is no N'Sync.
- Backstreet Boys are the top
selling boy band of all time.
- Well that's because they have,
With over 175 Million albums sold.
- Well that's because
they have eight albums
and N'Sync only has three.
- Where do you think
N'Sync is on the list?
- N'Sync only had to put out
three albums to be incredible
and BSB had to do eight.
- Alright, so you got mastermind,
Lou Pearlman, right here,
looks like Jabba The Hut, kinda.
- Lou Pearlman created N'Sync,
once the Backstreet Boys
were already successful.
The hits, everything,
- Got it right the second time.
- Yes, you say they're still touring?
Smash Mouth is playing Dave
& Buster's down the road.
Are we calling that a tour?
- They have more great
hits that can ignite
a karaoke room, that any boy
band that I can think of.
- They're all really boring.
- How dare you m'am.
- I'm gonna show you the shape of my heart
and I'm gonna say, that N'Sync
are just a bunch of losers.
- What about Howie? What about Nick?
- What about Howie?!
- When you talk hair,
you talk dance moves,
you talk songs, and you
just talk about sexiness,
N'Sync for the win.
- That whole singing in the rain thing,
with the shirts getting soaked,
that was the Backstreet Boys.
- N'sync gave us Justin Timberlake,
which gave us Justin and Britney,
which gave us matching denim outfits,
and ramen noodle hair.
- Backstreet Boys is a true band.
The true boy band.
A band that will live forever in my heart.
You've got JT and the rest.
Glorified backup dancers.
(triumphant music.)
- I think the thing we can both agree on
is that Backstreet Boyz, N'Sync,
still better than One Direction.
- Still better than One Direction.
- Boom!